well the beauty of being a liberal
political analyst in 2018 is it's really
simple no matter what the issue is or
the concern might be it's a safe bet
that you can tie it directly to Trump no
matter what hurricanes higher gas prices
the ongoing war or famine and absurdist
an even rose n bars Twitter feed all of
them are about Trump
watch this as college professor and
professional shakedown artist Michael
Eric Dyson shows how it's done this is
MSNBC last night well we got a bigot in
chief we got a racist in residence
that's what it is
he is unleashed some of the most
horrendous viewpoints bigotries and
racism in this country he's legitimated
them he's validated them he said look
it's it's okay come out the closet stand
up and speak straightforwardly and tell
the world what you believe we lost it's
unbelievable I know we all hate Trump
but to put stupid not stupid it's mark
Stein who joins us what do you make of
that I mean I feel like we're why I
don't want you know I don't want to
overstate and I want to be hysterical
like there but I feel like we're
watching actually something profound
they're melting down it looks like to me
yeah I think that's what's going on
Tucker I mean we live in a coarsened
culture and everybody has said that I
think one of the reasons why Samantha B
for example use the c-word is that the
f-word has been drained of it was it
when I believe it was Ken Tynan I think
who first said the f-word on TV on the
BBC back in the sixties the Irish
playwright Brendan bein had had done it
a couple years before but he was so
drunk that nobody actually understood
that that's the word he had years so
Penn Tainan got the Ken Tynan got the
credit for it on the BBC and that word
has so lost its force in part because
it's now said routinely on family shows
that they've had to move to Samantha B
had to move to the c-word what I find
interesting was the crowd went
deliriously wild about it there's no G
there there's no insight there there's
no particular point there but the fact
that she said the c-word has the has the
crowd well we really got a value for
money if we'd been here you know 120
years ago we'd have wanted to see a
trapeze artist or a tap dancer or an
Irish tenor but today we're happy to go
into a theatre and Cheer deliriously
when somebody says the c-word and that's
actually something that if anyone digs
that clip out in in several decades
they'll be they'll be interested to look
at I think well it really is like
looking at old pictures of the Cultural
Revolution from China with all these you
know children with it a little read
books and saluting all this nonsense
you're thinking how could a huge group
of people go simultaneously insane and
it's just mass hysteria it's a human
thing so what in the end is the effect
of this to normal people look on and say
Samantha bee has got to be Kathy Griffin
- two of the unhappiest people in
America I don't want anything they're
selling or do they say Wow sign me up
for whatever she's got no I think that
you're right to detect a certain
joylessness in it I think there's also a
logic though because we have to ink at
well on two incompatible tracks on the
one hand you have this general
coarsening f-word C word C word F word
but on the other you have evermore
protected protected classes of people so
your people you can't say anything about
big as a black they're gay they're
Muslim they're transgender whatever's
next down the pipe which means that it's
actually only people who are associated
with Trump or who are religious
conservatives or who are whatever it's a
very narrow sliver of people you can
unleash the blizzard of F and C words on
and that's the contradiction and and as
we've talked about before Tucker it's
actually killing comedy I mean the
fantastic thing about this clip is that
it's a supposed comedy show it's got
writers it's as Tammy was saying it's
pre-taped it's all carefully edited but
there actually isn't a joke in there
underneath that's just the word so if
you get as quickly I know it was only a
couple of years ago but remind me why
NBC fired Billy Bush he laughed at a
joke that was less vulgar than this and
he got fired and they destroyed his life
because why do you remember I don't
remember no exactly and that's and
that's the injustice here I mean
Roseanne who I don't think it's any kind
of conservative I know I've never said
that but Roseanne has had 40 years of
work vaporized over her treat and unlike
Samantha bee she's actually funny and
she was funny in a leftie way she had
lesbian kisses 30 years ago but her
lesbian kiss has been vaporized with
everything else because she happened
she's perceived as supporting Trump that
doesn't standard is ridiculous and it's
been scrubbed from on from digital you
can't fit second Dukes of Hazzard you
can't find it unbelievable mark Stein
thank you for chronicling this
revolution with us I appreciate it